Three out of four Indian women are unemployed.
That’s more than Saudi Arabia — a country where
women have only been allowed to drive since 2018.
This is no statistical sleight of hand. In fact,
“three out of four” is wildly conservative.
This number — called the “labor force
participation rate” includes both
anyone with or without a job — as long
as they’re looking, however passively.
Of those 24% of women technically in the
“labor force”, many don’t actually work.
Then there’s the question of
“what counts as ‘employment’?”
In this case, the answer is as little
as one hour each week of paid labor.
Put differently: of India’s 1.4
billion people, 681 million are women,
509 million of those are at least 15 years old,
122 million officially in the “labor force”,
and a tiny 38 million — 8.8% — according to
one Indian think-tank — meaningfully employed.
In a country of 1.4 billion, in other words,
just 38 million women have jobs.
The United States, by contrast,
has twice as many women employed — in absolute
terms — with only one-fourth the population.
How can that possibly be true?
Could it be that Indian households are now rich
enough to comfortably subsist on one income?
No, far from it. The country’s per
capita GDP is less than $2,400 — just
one-fifth the world average and where
China was about twenty years ago.
Is it because women lack access to education?
According to the World Bank,
“better educated women are more likely to
participate in the formal labor market”.
Again, no.
Strangely, in India, educated women
are less likely to find employment.
College enrollment has soared since the turn
of the century, yet women’s participation in
the labor force has actually been on
a steady decline until very recently.
Perhaps it’s precisely because women are
in school — studying, rather than working.
Nope. It’s not that either, since older
women are also missing from the labor force.
Finally, could it be an issue of
personal safety or cultural expectations?
Certainly this is a major piece of the puzzle.
India is one of the world’s most
dangerous countries for women.
Just getting to and from work safely
presents a not insignificant challenge.
Meanwhile, 99% of Indian women eventually get
married, 90% of those marriages are arranged,
and women are expected to do
nearly all of the housework.
An extraordinary six percent of men report doing
any cooking whatsoever and only
8% do at least some cleaning.
More of women’s time spent cooking and
cleaning is less time for paid labor.
Case: closed.
…Except, hang on — take a look at India’s
neighbor-on-three-sides, Bangladesh.
The two countries rank nearly identically on the
“Women’s Peace and Security Index” — that is,
very poorly. They share many of the same
cultural norms, practices, and beliefs.
…And yet, women in Bangladesh
work at a much higher rate.
Clearly there’s much more to this
story. What’s really going on?
The answer lies in this graph.
But first, a brief aside.
In India, like many countries,
a family’s honor depends on the
“purity” of its daughters. Any time
spent outside the home — for example,
at work — exposes women to accusations of
promiscuity, tarnishing her family’s honor.
Parents, therefore, strongly pressure
their daughters to stay home.
Of course, working also has its benefits —
children are expected to contribute financially.
This presents a trade-off between income and
honor. And since honor is more-or-less a constant,
the important variable here are
wages — for any given family,
is the extra money generated
by allowing your daughter to
work worth the damage to your reputation,
and, by extension, her marriage prospects?
When families are poor, this loss
of honor is strongly preferable to
the alternative — starvation. Women
have no choice; they have to work.
Conversely, when wages are high,
they offset this honor “penalty”,
causing women to rejoin the workforce.
India, as a country, is stuck at
the bottom of this “U” curve — what
Dr. Alice Evans of King's College
London calls the “patrilineal trap”.
Wages are just barely high enough that
families can scrape by on one income,
but not high enough to draw
women back to the workplace.
Women are trapped between low
wages and suffocating social norms.
They do go to college — though
mainly to find a husband.
And they do want to work. In a recent survey,
75% of teenage girls said they hoped
to find a job after graduating.
The problem is that wages aren’t high
enough to convince their families.
The real mystery, then, is why Indian
wages are still so incredibly low.
Since 1990, its economy has grown at an impressive
average rate of 6% a year — not so
far behind China’s miraculous 8.8%.
Back then, India was only the world’s
twelfth-largest economy. Today, it’s the fifth.
Yet somehow this spectacular
growth failed to create any jobs.
Now, economists call the number of new jobs
produced for every 1% change in
GDP the “elasticity of labor”.
Well, between 2011 and 19, the Indian labor
force grew by 0.26%, imputing an elasticity
of 0.04 — which is a polite way of saying
virtually zero jobs were created over 10 years.
This implies that if its economy were to double
overnight, employment would only increase by 4%.
Between 1999 and 2005, 60 million new jobs
appeared. Between 2004 and 10, just 3.
The result is fierce competition
for every last scrap of paid work.
In 2019, 12 million people
applied for 35,000 railroad jobs,
and 1.7 million for 1,500
jobs at a state-owned bank.
Most of these applicants are
young, and the vast majority
college-educated. Those who are both young and
college-educated don’t stand a chance. Today,
42% of Indians under 25 with
graduate degrees can’t find work.
So, what do all these young scholars do?
They go back to school, of course — fueling
a race to acquire an increasing number of
unnecessary credentials or else fall behind.
Others simply lose hope and spend their days doing
what Indians call “timepass” — aimless leisure.
Now, one clue to the whereabouts of
these missing jobs is the country’s
most common occupation — not salesperson,
waiter, or janitor but “CEO”. Truly.
You see, contrary to the image of sweatshops many
around the world imagine, Indian employers are
actually quite tightly regulated. Legally, they
must provide workers with paid leave, pensions,
and health insurance. They even need permission
from the government to fire or lay them off.
…At least, in principle.
In practice, most of these laws only apply
to businesses with 10 or more employees.
And, unrelatedly, for some odd reason Indian
companies seem to have decided nine
is the optimal number of workers.
So, what do you know — the vast majority of
businesses are exempt from these regulations.
Another reason they stay
small is to evade corruption.
Companies with 10 or more workers
are visited by labor inspectors,
many of which enforce arcane
rules to extract bribes.
Thus, whereas China has a healthy balance of
mid-size companies — many of which have between
51 and 200 workers, over 80% of Indian apparel
firms, for instance, have less than eight.
With so many small businesses,
it’s no wonder India has perhaps the
world’s highest density of “CEOs”.
As companies grow, rather than hire more workers,
they simply outsource this additional
labor to other small companies.
But this loophole — clever as it is — has a
cost: smaller companies are less productive.
On average, those with 50-199 workers are about
60% less productive than those with over 200,
and those with 5-49 workers
about 90% less productive.
Lower productivity means lower wages. Lower wages
mean less consumer demand. And
less demand means fewer jobs.
…Not just fewer but also lower quality.
Only 21% of Indian workers earn regular wages.
Of them, 46% don’t receive any paid leave,
53% don’t receive social security, and
nearly 60% have no written contract at all.
This “flexibility” — as employers call it — is
stressful and unpredictable
during the best of times.
When things are anything less than
peachy, these informal jobs become
downright catastrophic. Like,
say, during a global pandemic.
In 2020, the Prime Minister declared
what began as a three-week national
lockdown which immediately put
100 million Indians out of work,
who fled en masse to the countryside
— the only place they could go.
By December of that year, 75 million people had
been plunged below the poverty line of
$2 a day, according to Pew Research.
But there’s another, bigger, structural,
reason why India has so few jobs.
Of the countries that successfully
escaped poverty in the last hundred years,
almost all have pursued the same,
tried and true development recipe:
a rapid progression from agriculture to
manufacturing to services — in that order.
It worked for Taiwan, Hong Kong,
Singapore, South Korea, and now China.
India, on the other hand, seems
to have somehow missed this memo.
By the time its economy
liberalized in the early 1990s,
China was already ten years into this journey.
And having started so late, Indian
factories couldn’t compete with their
Chinese competitors. So, they largely gave up.
Instead, India skipped straight from
agriculture to services — leaving out
that very critical middle step
in the recipe: manufacturing.
Today, Vietnam — with a population of
less than a hundred million — exports
more clothing than India, with
a population of 1.4 billion.
Now, there’s nothing wrong with services. Nearly
all rich countries are service economies — from
the U.S. to Japan and Switzerland. So
you might think India found a shortcut.
The country has an impressive depth of finance,
insurance, real estate, and technology expertise.
Deloitte, Goldman, and Tata pay their Indian
consultants and bankers top-dollar — much more,
of course, than most factory workers.
The problem is that there just
aren’t that many of these jobs.
As Indian farmers have grown more productive,
as they have across the globe, agriculture has
been on a steady decline. No surprise there.
Usually, however, all these farmers
would become factory workers. One
labor-intensive industry replaced with another.
But, as you can see, manufacturing
hasn’t absorbed these displaced farmers.
Sure, these new service jobs have
helped — just not nearly enough.
So, in order to make up the difference,
Indians have flocked to construction.
These jobs are often temporary,
low-paid, and physically dangerous.
But this trend is particularly bad for women.
In East Asia, where manufacturing replaced
agriculture — women became factory workers,
which slowly influenced social expectations
and afforded them newfound freedom.
In India, women were pushed out
of farming but discouraged from
taking on construction. A few lucky
women secured lucrative service jobs.
But the vast majority simply left the labor
market altogether. They had nowhere to go.
This is why India’s economy continued
to grow — those new service jobs are
very very productive — while the number of
jobs did not — they’re few and far between.
It’s why women in Bangladesh work at much
higher rates — its many factories provide
them with a socially-acceptable place to
do so, whereas India has no such scale.
What India does have — that
most of Asia does not — is time.
China’s population peaked last year
and its labor force is expected to
decrease by about 1% every year starting in 2030.
India, meanwhile, is still
very much young and growing.
40% of its population is under the age of 25,
and 53% under 30. Its median age is a youthful
28, compared to China’s 38, or Japan’s 48.
With any luck, India has about
two-decades remaining in its
“demographic window” — a critical
transition period during which a
country has a large number of working-age
people compared to children and retirees.
If the country can harness this labor,
it could still experience a taste of the
demographic dividend that propelled China
from a poor to a middle-income country.
By merely employing women at the same rate as men,
according to Bloomberg, India’s economy
could grow by nearly a third by 2050.
But, if it wastes this opportunity, these excess
young people could become a demographic burden.
In that case, it would be stuck
with millions of angry, aimless,
and unemployed 20, 30, and 40 year-olds.
Simply put: India has no time to
waste, which means it may need some
help from David Allen in his book Getting
Things Done on today’s sponsor, Imprint.
In it, for example, I learned the 5
stages of being productive and when
to put something on my to-do list versus calendar.
These days, no one can keep up with
the endless stream of new books,
movies, or knowledge — nevermind
catch up on all of history.
But Imprint condenses these lessons into
bite-sized, visual, and interactive lessons — not
unlike these videos — making you more widely
read and culturally aware in less time.
Instead of scrolling mindlessly through
Instagram, wouldn’t you rather check out
those classic works you’ve always heard about
but never had time to sit down and read,
like Guns, Germs, and Steel or
Malcolm Gladwell’s Outliers?
In addition to book summaries, Imprint
also has lessons on current events,
like Russia’s war in Ukraine,
and interactive explanations,
for example, of history’s
great philosophical thinkers.
To start learning today, click the link on screen
or in the description for a free 7-day trial.
The first 200 to click that link will also
get 20% off an annual premium subscription.